welcome to this video Marco corvy feed a
master from Italy the Dutch let's let's
try something wacky em the storm gambit
I've played this evening tournament
chess once ok so I'm playing it and keep
it simple method just returning the poem
it's not very critical for a white stone
is slightly shaky opening for whatever
it is it's interesting there are some
interesting points then surprise that is
taking some time here
aha ok he's going for long castles
interesting ok i will try to do
something here on the on the queenside
yeah this is a bit like the sicilian
right he's got the f file instead of the
the C file and add some add some
Sicilian themes but it looks to me like
white is very quick here if I if I if
this looks like a very strong type of
Dragon ok for a 5m I guess
yeah if it takes I get I just go to the
sada can can ignore it let's let's see
him check
maiya ke cannot take with a pony and so
I must take with that check check it
looks like total devastation really so
um like be five year yeah this is just
like the dragon in a very very nice form
for wide yeah this is sort of the last
bullet Icahn fire gives g3 are just
keeping it closed
yeah yeah I thought that rook f5 should
win okay let's let's do it like that
take here first Queen takes and then
route 85 takes this d6 and why does your
white is smashing through threatening
Queen a 77 made and the capture is just
a an automatic made with the rook coming
to be one
I really don't like the idea of castling
long there I don't know it did look like
a very quick attack for what
I needed to take on f6 first for this
combination because if there was still
nada foreign Queen on the 70 could have
removed the deep on to try to catch in
you black resigns you know it's just
like that here check check and what is
meeting this looked very quick I mean if
we consider heap castled long or maybe
he needs to do some some other means of
code to play on the computer is already
on plus one point something recommending
p sacrifices on deform but I think we
are nearing the point where it's um
after a five white is winning out well I
don't really think that this is this is
Genesis playable if you cancel long you
you need to do something else and I mean
black can just cancel shorter and
there's nothing nothing wrong about it
it's it's pretty much an okay position
we both have decent development and in
pieces should be about equal nothing
special going on comp gives white a
slight edge now maybe I would like to
given the choice I would take white but
it's nothing that should terrify black
very much okay thanks for watching